trance cytosis is a type of trance
cellular transport by which various
micro macromolecules such as several
enzymes proteins and antibodies are
transported across the interior of the
cell so one side the proteins come in
get endocytosed and from the other side
it gets exocytosed and released this
kind of mode of transit transport is
important for several secretary
molecules and we will take an example to
understand this process one of the most
important antibodies that are secreted
in breast milk tears or saliva is IgA we
would look at how IG a antibody is trans
I toast so we look at the pressed inside
which there are mammary gland now here
is a small zoomed in version of the
mammary gland and if we zoom in further
we would see the epithelial cells and
the lumen where we can see in the milk
droplets now from the outside of this
epithelial surface the antibodies has to
go inside into the lumen from where it
would be secreted along with the breast
milk so in a bigger picture we can
understand outside of the epithelial
cell surfaces there are antibody
producing plasma cell so it produce IgA
type antibodies which then bind to poly
IG our receptor on the epithelial cell
surface then it gets endocytosed
from one surface second it would
transport it it would transport it along
the transport route of the cell and get
exocytosed from the other surface it has
been seen that disrupting the golgi
architecture by prefilled in a can
disrupt these trans I ptosis
that means this transyl Euler transport
is called d dependent so this is an
important process because this is how
several secretory antibodies are
secreted in the bodily secretions like
breast milk or saliva it set
I hope you enjoyed this video apart from
IgA LDL is also sometime trans I toast I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you